I'm here this idiot welcome to jazz
Caucasia maybe the first run Twins that
introduced from underwater
sometimes it's really hard to organize a
conference with it I haven't had an
aquarium available today so I'm sorry I
couldn't do the underwater thing again
welcome to disk on a shine yes pretty
who knows seperti and wants to
participate please apply
you
good morning everybody and welcome to
the fifth j/s con fascia here in
Singapore super glad you're all here I
hope you'll be excited can I hear you a
little bit okay great I can't believe
we're here five years was definitely not
what I set out for when we started in
2012 with the first jazz camp and I
don't know if you know the story behind
it it was a friend of mine Sebastian and
I who decided to create a community
conference because we didn't know where
all these developers were in Singapore
we couldn't find them like we found
ourselves here working with web
technologies and where we were coming
from from Europe like we knew a lot of
people doing this but here somebody seem
to be creating websites they're all over
the place but we had no idea where there
were so we thought okay let's create a
conference and see who all these people
are and turns out 300 people actually
showed up and I wanted to show you a few
pictures that we have from then and this
is it still true as it was in 2012 we're
still the closest JavaScript conference
to Java still holds true so this is 2012
this is the humble beginnings how it
started with a few friends of mine and
we pulled up some inflatable palm trees
and thought let's do is our school
conference this is how it looked 300
people showed up and a few things you
might actually still see at jay's convey
sure this year the Jimmy monkey flac in
the back there they're the same guys
doing the coffee for you today and it
still is good and we had a surprising
amount of great people coming by from
all over the places judge me to join
doesn't 2012 and Joshua Joshua are you
here today to risk you for CSS come for
sure yesterday and he stuck around to
can you wave there in the back if you
have a good Wi-Fi connection today it's
because of Fred who did it the first
year and he actually build
more company around providing Wi-Fi for
events after this and this guy maybe
he's already in the audience he is also
one of the guys who stuck around he gave
one of the first talks the one in the
back yawn he's going to give a talk
about Hardware this year again I think
it's his third talk at chess conf Asia
so we have a lot of people that stick
with us I think Simon is he already here
too he's going to do talk later after
lunch like he's also one of our
favorites like I think this is going to
be his fourth talk here like yeah last
year I told him Simon I can't have you
on every year like we need other people
to and then he came and gave a lightning
talk in the break as an audience member
so the whole team 2012 which I couldn't
have done it without that's how he
started the first 300 brave souls said
thought yay conference in nature sounds
great let's go that was the year
afterwards that was in Manila was
slightly smaller in back then I was
still naive enough to think it would be
easy to just have a conference travel
around Southeast Asia and be organized
in every city every year it was really
tough but it was a great event
afterwards 2014 slowly growing that was
last year 2015 5 years can I actually
see who was here 2012 just a show of
hands I see young yeah that's correct i
see CJ we have a few souls that came who
is here all five years actually I at
least saw two names coming up and I did
the Kree myself and I wonder if they are
here already and can identify themselves
I think that's super cool that we are
able to do a conference like this year
of the year and have so many people show
up and the main idea behind it is still
the same we still want to know where all
these web developers in Southeast Asia
and want to talk to them and make sure
that we create more people that want to
come into web development
and create a welcoming community around
it and that's kind of the word that I
want to stick the conference around is
the community building aspect of it so
during the next two days make sure you
find as many interesting people to talk
to that you can possibly find we're
going to have life chest tonight where
there's going to be great performances
and together with a bunch of drinks so
you can talk and roam around and then
George our script giving your
entertainment time and we're going to
have the five-year anniversary party
tomorrow at the great escape where you
are happy to join in and pay with your
brackets for drinks and just make sure
you go home with the most learnings in
the most new contexts that you can
possibly find I also want to give out a
shout out to the good guys from Palo IT
who are participating in deaf West Asia
and they had a workshop last weekend
where I think eight to ten people that
just found themselves i signed up
randomly i had to create a mobile app in
two days and they actually succeeded in
doing so it's online as a mobile website
on conf match com so you can try it out
it's a very simple thing is an app with
your github and you can put in your
interests and see if you find other
people that you want to connect with in
this event or other deaf fest event that
fest came actually about three years ago
as a simple list of events that happened
around the conference because people
were with bothering me is like can you
put my event on your website for the
conference because I want all these
awesome people to come to my event too
and eventually create ad FS as a
separate website that would list all of
those events and last year grew bigger
and bigger this year we have 21 events
more than 1,200 registered attendees for
all these events this is I think the
16th or 17th event as part of deaf fest
this year and FS has now an official
vision to which is to enhance digital
expertise in Asia emphasize on
collaboration and build community so
with all of this community talk let's
get some more community talk
you